sending the lefty
tyler alexander out to the mound today
he's making his sixth start of the
season
and he made his only career appearance
against baltimore on september 16
2019
didn't factor in a decision his last
start on tuesday in minneapolis against
the twins
and he's looking to do something
to qualify him as a starter in aj's mind
and away we go
and away goes austin hayes with a fair
ball down the left field line to the
side wall and that will be a double on
the very first pitch of the game for
austin hayes his first hit of the series
and everybody be quiet huh
how about that first pitch looking he
gets a fastball right where he's looking
and jerks it
down the third base line easily a fair
ball so a good start for the orioles a
good start for austin hayes here's ryan
mout castle with a runner at third one
out
ride a first pitch swing a fly ball
muscled out to center this will get at
least one run in back to the wall and
off the wall but dude hurls it in and
mount castle is aboard its second base
so two doubles on the first pitch for
the orioles here in the first inning
hayes to start it and mount castle to
drive him in one nothing baltimore
anthony santander
well the orioles read the scouting
report and you're right tyler alexander
throws a lot of strikes it's a four to
one strikeout to walk ratio he likes to
fill it up but he's left some balls
pretty hittable spots and the orioles
have taken advantage of it early
santander golf's one to center field
another well struck ball but due on the
run this is over badou's glove as well
it will be a third double and four
batters in the first inning and the
orioles offense a battering ram on the
first six pitches against alexander and
there is spencer watkins making his
fifth career start see the two-in-one
record 310 era not a big strikeout guy
14 strikeouts nine walks was outstanding
his first three starts only allow one
run in each of those three
this is where detroit has to do some
damage now
two walks got a young kid on the ropes a
little bit early in the ball game
you got to make them pay for these walks
jamer candelario can do just that
there's pitch number 21 on its way to
candelario
sharply farrell and off the glove of
mancini
grossman will score cabrera to third the
tigers are on the board
eric haas now with a chance to deliver a
two-out hit here's the 3-1 to haas
jolted to deep center field back goes
mckenna that ball's over his head off
the wall cabrera trots home here comes
candelario
hoss clears the bases with a two run two
love double tigers are in the lead
thanks to the wizard from westland of
course you never know how the other
team's gonna counter maybe they come out
swinging expecting you to switch
so it's just making better pitches you
can you can use the same pitches you got
to make oh my god what a play by harold
castro
he does his best willie may's imitation
back to the plate right in front of his
center fielder and austin hayes can't
believe it this is a thing of beauty
right here you want good defense
this is difficult to duplicate track
record of not getting through five here
we are in the fourth so already aj's got
one of the bullpen guys throwing
he strikes out mckenna to start the four
yes sir
comes back and
ends up
striking him out second strike out of
the game for tyler maybe get him a
couple more innings
mix them in with the other ones
this could be a quick out but franco
slips he still gets it to first are you
serious michael franco
from the sand
well he did it remember he did it last
night not to that degree bob won last
night and recovered
and got it across it was a replay but
hit the call stand watch this backhand
hilda glove he goes to stop slips down
and from his seat
a one hop
to hop perfect throw
over to trey mancini
mancini to center field
badu started slowly now he dives and
makes the grab all of a sudden he
realizes i got to get in on this
takes a few extra
lunging strides and dives at the ball
makes a good catch grossman waiting on a
note 2 from spencer watkins grossman
puts a charge into one in the right
center field that'll bounce up against
the wall he's got eyes on three
hits the bag turning hard and he's into
third base with a stand-up triple
grossman a one-out triple here in the
sixth let's just hope they make a
mistake that miggy can capitalize on
fly ball down the right field line
santander gets behind it makes it in
foul territory grossman's gonna tag and
he will score there's miguel cabrera at
his finest and the smart base runner
gets a great jump
and gets home it's gonna take a perfect
throw
but miggy has done it so many times in
his career
castro to the right center field gap oh
harold that will get down and all the
way to the wall
castro cruises in he's got himself a
leadoff double here in the seventh no
penalty for adding on
harold had a couple swings inside that
he would like to have back but this one
he made good contact
in the hole and through into left field
they're gonna hold harold castro runners
at the corners for the tigers
back-to-back hits to start the seventh
maquil badu looking for his first hit in
the
game today here's the 2-2
he'll do it again
another run trots home akeel badou comes
through with runners in scoring position
it's 5-2 detroit
the 3-0 he swung at it
shallow right
santander
is under it here comes the tag from
griner
and he's going to score
always surprised everybody in the
ballpark
[Music]
well that's just having a good scouting
report on the throwing arm and the arm
strike of santander 17 000 plus on their
feet here at comerica park
on the ground to second harold castro
throws him out gregory soto does his job
and the tigers
salvage a split with baltimore a 6-2 win
they've won 11 of their last 13 at home